[Music]
my name is John Bristol and I am the
owner of Super Fresh detailing and
sanitation and we operate within
Trinidad and Tobago in today's video I
will be cleaning a three-piece
microfiber cup set
for this particular set the client was
actually considering replacing it
completely and getting a new one but
they decided since they were aware of
the cleaning services that they would
give it a try to see if they could delay
the purchase just for a few more months
although this set looks like it may be a
letter set what you're actually seeing
is a lot of build up on the surface
itself it is actually a microfiber couch
which means we're able to use our
regular process to get it cleaned
this couch has never been cleaned since
it was bought in my experience the
microfiber sets are usually dirtier than
other cotton or synthetic fibers
depending on the age of the sofa and
where it's located you build up on it
would consist of different things even
environments typically leave persons
with a lot more sweat on their skin
which in turn ends up on the couch this
is one of the dirtiest cultures I have
encountered currently looks dark brown
with some areas being black
thank you
due to how soiled the coach was I spray
on the simple green Degreaser which
makes to break down the dirt and oils
and then wait 10 minutes for it to work
before I start scrubbing I generally
apply the free spray evenly placing
extra emphasis on the areas that are
more solid I am careful not to apply too
much to avoid overheating the fabric and
to reduce the chances of splatter once I
start scrubbing now that that 10 minute
period has passed I can start scrubbing
scrubbing is that mechanical action that
helps break down the larger pieces of
debris and makes everything ready for
extraction later on using a variable
speed polisher with a brush attachment I
begin scrubbing starting at the crevices
and working my way to the flat of
portions of the surface in this case I
have to make multiple passes with the
machine as well as scrubbing and
spraying
after scrubbing once I see that the
soils have sufficiently been broken down
I move on to the actual extraction
here our equipment sprays in a solution
of Clean Water fabric shampoo and
deodorizer and Vacuums at the same time
this means that the debris that is on
the surface of the couch is rinsed away
with every pass of our machine
taking the coach panel by panel I
started the edges where the crevices are
and whipped my way over the smoother
areas I'm also careful to make multiple
passes where the couch was most soiled
after cleaning the love seat and
Consulting the owner I can now move on
to the rest of the set
of the condition of the Wastewater I'll
make extra passes on this scout set to
ensure that we get all of the data
the most difficult thing about cleaning
this couch in particular is the amount
of time that it's taking this course
took between five and six hours to clean
not an unfinished cleaning this set is
going to be damped to the touch however
it's only going to be about three to
four hours for it to be fully dry and
ready to use again a yearly cleaning
would ensure that the dust through its
sweat as well as other contaminants
don't have the opportunity to
significantly build up on your sofa and
affect the air quality and overall
hygiene in your home
after the process of cleaning the scotch
the natural light brown has been
restored
plants were really satisfied with the
end result and they were able to delay
purchasing an entire new set for a while
[Music]